there's a leaky going the world what
right do you have to the art and work of
other people that shared on the net why
are you blocked from sharing photos of
buildings in one country and not in
another questions for the digital age
that Parliament grappled with this week
as the European Commission prepares to
reform legislation dating from 2001 that
was designed to improve access to
Europe's cultural diversity was supposed
to make the exchange of knowledge and
culture across our borders easier but in
all the relevant points it has left the
decisions up to the Member States if you
want people to really communicate across
borders and to form a common European
public then they have to have the legal
security as well as harmonization of
copyright law emmy peas are demanding
better access to shows blocked in third
countries and a better balance between
the rights of consumers and authors la
la aunty shakeela you know fabricación
de verdad el vol Corelli mishanti olaf
initial doc say oh pues nada said Matt
apoorva viva la la activity a commercial
Ibaka second of all share a portage a
laser mep is voted in favor of the
recommendations but dropped proposals to
change current rules on photographing
public buildings for commercial use